في لفته طيبه وعمل انساني نبيله قامت
عائله سعوديه حفل زفاف لعمل لديها اسمه
جهير وشاركته هذه الفرحه جميله جدا ووثق
مقطع فيديو متداول لحظات اقامه الزفاف
وظهر العريس مرتديا الثوب والبشت السعودي
تزفه سيارات وسط اجواء من الفرحه والسعاده
الفيديو المتداول لحفل الزفاف اثار تفاعلا
واسعا من رواد مواقع التواصل الذي رحبوا
بتصرف الاسره
لفته جميله وانسانيه يعني بشكل هائل ليش
قررتوا يعني انكم تحتضنوا شهير لهذه
الدرجه لحتى تزوجوه كمان زهير طبعا عمل
معنا وقت يعني الحمد لله من اربع سنوات
الى خمس سنوات لاحظنا في
الامانه والاخلاص والتفاني وحبه العمل
واعجبنا اكثر في برضو
بره بوالديه يعني جاهير انت اليوم
هل انت فرحان شنو اللي يعني لك انه انه
هذه الاسره السعوديه تقيم لك هذا العرس مو
في بنغلاديش في السعوديه السلام عليكم انا
اشكركم وانا حبي زياده سعودي اوروبيه انا
ما شاء الله
قبل شوف في حفله صديق انا سعودي انا رو ما
شاء الله تبارك الله يجي يعني كويس انا
يعني كلام
[موسيقى]
لاحظت فيه يعني حبه رغبته اني احقق لها
الامنيه وادخل السرور عليه وعلى عائلته
والحمد لله والعائله عندي برضو عملت كفريق
واحد يعني معي لا انسى طبعا في هذه
المناسبه هذه المقابله ام طلال برضه
زوجتي قامت برضه باعمال ثانيه
من استقبال العروس وعمل الكوشه لها
والذهاب الى صاله الحفل مثل ما يعمل
للعريس السعودي يعني عملنا غرفه عمليات
صغيره
نعم في انجاز هذا العمل يعني
[موسيقى]